je m'appelle Michelle Darnell et je suis la
femme la plus riche d'Amérique à quel point
je suis riche Je voulais descendre sur un
Phoenix doré et je suis sûr que je l'ai fait Je dirige
votre opération tout en étant une mère célibataire
Je mérite une augmentation de salaire tu as un  enfant
ouais j'ai généralement une sorte d'
ambiance asexuée tu es en état d'arrestation pour délit d'initié
tu es en faillite tous tes comptes
ont été gelés clairement trouve-moi un nouvel
avocat tu n'as pas d'argent espèce de
mère rousse stupide si elle n'en a pas  je n'ai
nulle part où aller elle devrait rester ici
regarde que je suis dans le canapé attention c'est un
peu capricieux ce n'est pas si mal Oh
Michelle tu dois sortir du bain
oh mon dieu je suis des vêtements autobronzants ta
chambre aide  moi, dis-moi si tu as des
stries sur mes ischio-jambiers oh mon dieu whoa
alors tu dois te lever du canapé emmener
Rachel à ses pissenlits rencontrer notre
tube est arrivé avec les cent quatre-vingt
neuf mille dollars saint ce qui est
donc c'est ma façon  de retour, nous allons commencer un
empire brownie et enseigner à ces g  irls de
vraies compétences en affaires nous voulons de bonnes
recrues allez pour les filles agressives qui
est cette bête Krista Delvecchio vous savez que
les épaves de train ont toujours des noms de strip-teaseuse
que regardez-vous qui l'a
mise sur la liste trou dans un cône d'accord
cristal que disons-nous  si quelqu'un
ne veut pas acheter acheter mes brownies ou
je te tue
ne dis pas ce cristal
Hé qu'est-ce que tu penses que tu fais
c'est là que les pissenlits vendent ce fait est
brûlé
Wow ce pull dit juste que je
t'abandonne  Je me sens très précaire
juste avant mon rendez-vous si vous pouviez entendre
ces tristes bassets dire peut-être que
Claire a mis un bourgeon qui est normalement
quelqu'un s'il vous plaît allez m'installer dans votre
jean laissez-moi voir ça Clara c'est comme
Geppetto